deux tribunes pour deux visions du
féminisme la première est parue dans le
monde une centaine de familles rejette
ce qu'elle considère comme la haine des
hommes
le texte est signé entre autres par
l'actrice catherine deneuve ou encore
l'auteur catherine millet elles
défendent une liberté d'importuner et
dénonce un puritanisme qui enfermerait
les femmes dans leur statut de victime
pour elle le viol est un crime mais la
drague insistante ou maladroites n'est
pas un délit fin de citation
une déclaration à contre courant du
mouvement de dénonciation d agression
sexuelle n'est de la sphère veinstein la
réponse ne s'est pas fait attendre
les ports et leurs alliés s'inquiètent
c'est normal leurs vieux monde est en
train de disparaître peut-on lire dans
une autre tribune publiée celle-là sur
france info dans ce texte la militante
féministe caroline de haas la présidente
des chiennes de garde marie noëlle bas
et une trentaine d'autres femmes ont
contré point par point les arguments de
la tribune du monde
le risque d'excès par exemple on
risquerait d'aller trop loin
l'excès c'est maintenant répond la
tribune des militantes féministes qui
rappelle que chaque jour des milliers de
femmes sont victimes de harcèlement on
ne pourrait plus dragué d'après la
tribune du monde faux peut-on lire dans
celle de france info il ne faut pas
confondre la séduction où l'on considère
l'autre comme son égal et la violence ou
le consentement de la femme est exclue
les unes considèrent les femmes comme
les victimes de violence les autres
refusent ce statut
deux conceptions du féminisme totalement
opposé à hautmont dudin conception
incarnée sur ce plateau avec nous pour
ce match des ide elisabeth lévy vous
êtes la directrice de la rédaction de
causeur et vous avez donc signé cette
tribune dieu du monde intitulé nous
défendons une liberté d'importuner
indispensable à la liberté sexuelle
fatima benomar face à vous vous êtes co
porte parole de l'association féministe
les effrontés et vous vous avez signé
une contre tribune sur france info
intitulé les ports et leurs alliés et es
ont raison de s'inquiéter merci à toutes
les deux d'être avec nous ce soir
elisabeth lévy nous avons contacté
plusieurs signataires de cette tribune
du monde dont une corinne erhel
par exemple qui est psychanalyste et
qu'ils se soient un petit peu dépassé
notamment par les réactions à cette
tribune que vous avez tous deux signés
elle dit je suis un peu catastrophé par
certaines des signataires et leurs
commentaires et surtout par l'ampleur
que cela prend
est ce que vous vous assumez tout de
cette tribune où est ce que vous êtes
quand même un petit peu troublée par ces
contre réaction je ne suis pas troublé
par les contrecoups je suis révolté si
vous voulez par le torrent d'injures
on a tout à fait le droit de nous
critiquer ne met pas tout le monde dans
le même sac mais je suis révolté par le
torrent d'injures
maintenant je crois qu'il ya une chose
qui est très clair moi j'ai signé ce
texte
donc je vais vous dire que je l'assumé
je veux bien expliquer un certain nombre
de explicite est à mon avis un certain
nombre de phrases drogba qui a été très
mal comprise mais j'assume ce texte
en revanche que madame ehrenberg se
sentent tout à fait libres non réaction
et nos commentaires nous appartiennent à
chacune en propre et la première chose
que je voudrais dire et je voudrais le
dire à ma contradictrice avec amitié et
je suis très sérieusement on nous parle
de la libération de la parole des femmes
d'accord c'est très bien que la parole
des femmes se libère me dit oh je suis
tout à fait prête à l'entendre mais on
ne peut pas dire que la parole se libère
et 10 est exigé qu'elle aille dans ce
sens là sinon ça n'est plus une
libération c'est un embrigadement je
demande le droit ou pluralisme et je
demande le droit aux désaccords sans
être insulté la disqualification des
auteurs si vous voulez au prétexte que
ce serait des bourgeoises notamment de
catherine deneuve incarne pourtant quand
excusez moi quand des femmes ont dénoncé
harvey weinstein
c'était des prolétaires c'était des
caissières
ça n'était pas des privilégiés il se
trouve que quand des privilégiés dit ce
qu'on veut entendre
on trouve ça génial et sinon leurs
paroles n'aurait pas deux poids ou pas
de légitimité parce qu elle parce que
elles sont privilégiés non c'est juste
qu'on peut se poser la question de
catherine deneuve qui a probablement peu
pris le métro dans sa vie ou récemment
envoyé ce que je veux dire c'est
peut-être là le problème de légitimité
de ses signataires du monde on va
peut-être entendre fatima benomar ce qui
nous a mis en colère c'est effectivement
ce décalage de ce convoi nous comme
association par rapport à la prise de
parole des femmes qui subissent le
harcèlement les agressions et les viols
et ce qui était en train d'être redit
dans cette tribune c'est dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'on est déjà arrivé à une
heure où dès qu'un homme fait des
avances 20 ce qu'il appelait lourdingue
à une femme elle va aller porter plainte
le problème qu'on a en france c'est que
même quand elles vivent des choses
extrêmement graves comme des
harcèlements des agressions et des viols
les ja que 10% des femmes violées qui
porte plainte et qu'elles vont au
contraire intériorisé que c'est leur
faute culpabiliser pour vous c'est le
fric usage année le discrédit sur tout
le mouvement balle en fait elle a jeté
la confusion par exemple typiquement on
a nous a dit pendant des années que en
utiliser l'expression main aux fesses ou
frotteur sont des expressions qui nous
semblent faits mise en doute par rapport
à ce que vivent les femmes et notamment
des jeunes femmes c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans mythes ou c'est que ça
montre vraiment l'ampleur des à la fois
des pédocriminalité aussi de ce que des
violences qui arrivent de façon précoce
puisque souvent les fraudeurs ils vont
aller vers des femmes à ces jeunes parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils auront pourront pas
facilement se défendre et enflammé
l'érable mais voilà les plus vulnérables
en général mais bon c'est qu'il était
extrêmement énervant c'était cette
confusion entre les rapports de
séduction qui sont des rappels de
plaisir mon corps d'un homme me plaît
qui vient de me faire des avances j'ai
des étoiles dans les yeux j'ai des
papillons dans le ventre j'en parle à
mes copines
ah là là et le fccla économistes vont
aller ou pas les groupes et désherber
s'il vous plaît et s'il me plaît pas
mais en général je suis quelqu'un de
très poli je suis désolé monsieur je me
suis pas intéressé sait s'il insiste
qu'il ya voilà en propre en fait le
problème c'est leur cause il ya là
beaucoup d'hommes si je finis un maître
ya beaucoup d'hommes qui quand une femme
dit non entre dans une phase punitive
c'est à dire qui lui commence à lui
faire regretter d'avoir dit non c'est ça
les comportements de harcèlement qu'on
dénonce elysées paris dès le départ qui
dès le départ
son ex prêtre aussi ça c'est ce qu'on va
plutôt dans l'espace public exprès
grossier parce que ce qu'ils cherchent
le plaisir qu'ils cherchent en tant que
arcelor c'est la confrontation c'est la
résistance et ça c'est les mecs ils vont
tout de suite vous tutoyez il dit bon tu
as un beau cul machin est tout sauf que
ça va pas nous plaire et il crée une
situation de violence et d'humiliation
et de cette attaque il s'appelait la
veille être abordée en le tutoyant dans
une soirée s'appelait ya des femmes à
qui sa plainte il n'est pas très mal en
ce froid
non non non non je parle là excusez moi
il faut être précis voilà c'est à dire
jeudi il ya des pas maquillée tutoyer ne
déplaît pas excusez moi de vous le dire
alors la première chose d'abord que vous
ayez été énervé c'est très bien pu vous
accusiez alors je n'ai pas je me
rappelle pas votre tribune mot par mot
qu'on nous accuse de défendre les
violeurs que la première phrase de la
tribune et le viol est un crime
si vous voulez ne me convient pas du
tout là dedans c'est effectivement je le
dis pour les téléspectateurs l'avaient
la militante féministe caroline de haas
qui signe cette contre tribune les
signataires de la tribune du monde sont
pour la plupart des récidivistes en
matière de défense de pédocriminels ou
d'apologie du viol de pablo catherine
deneuve pour revenir du swing au nom va
pas pour le nom catherine de 90 ans
récents sont garés là et réactions sont
gentils ici ça vous ennuie pas et je
trouve que le fait tienne parole
dissidente si la parole des femmes se
libère elle doit se libérer dans toutes
sortes de sens il n'ya pas un grand
parti des femmes au tout le monde doit
penser pareil
il se trouve que un certain nombre de
femmes et pas seulement des privilégiés
pas seulement des journalistes nous
envoyons aussi vous n'avez pas le
monopole d'une vérité vous voyez
d'ailleurs par votre fonction je pense
beaucoup de femmes qui effectivement ont
été agressés mais le tableau pour me
dresse l'on m'explique en quelque sorte
que la situation des femmes aujourd'hui
serait beaucoup plus dur que quand
catherine deneuve avait 20 ans où on
pouvait entendre des gens dans des films
dire à l'état bourgeois studio à claquer
le beignet si vous voulez aujourd'hui
les jo moi je suis né dans le monde
égalité si un homme s'adresse à moi
saoulé en me disant en me disant comme
un homme l'a dit à sandra muller ce qui
lui a suffi pour l'appeler mon bourreau
tu as des greniers margerie de faire
jouir ça peut me dérange et ça peut mais
nerveuse et ça peut me faire marrer mais
en août yatch à sanaa temps à ma dignité
mais mal d'éliminer ville départ de moi
pardonnez moi est ce vous avez sur votre
mère ou plus je m'en serais quand même
la question étaient des femmes est
différente aussi selon les femmes et que
vous êtes une femme forte
non ce que j'essaye de vous dire je
trouve que dont j'essaye de dire autre
chose j'essaye de dire que avant le
corps risation avant on disait que le
corps des femmes que la vertu des femmes
leur honneur était logé entre leurs
cuisses et si un homme avait touché ni
femme si elle avait couché avec des
hommes volontairement ou pas d'ailleurs
elle était perdue c'était une famille
déshonoré moi je considère que si un
homme me touche
sans mon consentement c'est pas mon
honneur qui a atteint il ne peut pas
mieux milliers d'accords parce que quand
ça que j'aime beaucoup de femmes quand
même qu'ils se retrouvent dans des
situations qui sont ces la situation
c'est pas elle c'est la situation qui
est humiliante et qui a été pensée en
tant que tel on parle bien de les cas de
harcèlement d'agression et de violer le
problème qu'on la sait très bien que
vous dites que vous vous arrivez être
forte
le problème c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
femmes mois là une fois j'ai été
agressée sexuellement mais d'une force
j'aime j'ai cogité pendant des semaines
pour dire si c'est pas moi qui étais mal
habillés ou si c'est pas moi qui ait
provoqué cette situation parce qu'il ya
tout un discours qui est culpabilisant
et ce qui était génial avec mais tout
c'est qu'il ya eu une libération de
milliers de femmes qui en écoutant les
témoignages des autres ont su identifier
que ce qu'elles ont vécu c'était grave
vous me disiez que certaines femmes
privilégiant vécu des violences
évidemment mais est ce que ça ne vous
interpelle pas les affaires par exemple
des escales beaupain evine stein tout le
monde a dit après tout le monde savait
walston bah oui ça fait 40 ans tout le
monde sait et pourtant le maire tas a
régné pendant ces décennies ça veut bien
dire que même des femmes dans une
situation une position sociale où elle
pouvait se défendre ont été mises dans
des situations où elle se sentait pas
autorisé légitimé à parler plus c'est
moi c'est nous enterrer la vérité dans
les si elle n'ose
t'es pas par autoriser l abbé peur pour
leur carrière donc dans le boulot vous
ne alors permettez-moi quoi bon en tout
cas il ya beaucoup de femmes parce que
je vous ai quand même beaucoup laissé
parler et nous et ce qui est important à
dire parce que ça a été soulignée dans
votre tribune
c'est cette histoire de statut de
victime nous ce qu'on dit c'est que
justement la plupart des femmes elles se
sont plutôt coupable et responsable
ou du moins complice quand il lui arrive
des violences à ce sont les témoignages
qu'on a tous les jours qu'elle n'avait
pas la teneur et d'appareils dans le
statut de victime justement on a
l'impression que vous dites que c'est
intériorisé c'est dire qu'elles
deviennent victimes comme si ça faisait
partie de leur identité au contraire
quand par exemple quand vous avez su
bien je fais un con brio là je vous
allez dans un commissariat jeudi j'ai
été victime d'un cambriolage vous dites
pas que victime et votre statut
personnel vous revendiquez vous dénoncez
vous externalisez la responsabilité j'ai
été victime d'une violence ça veut dire
c'est pas ma faute c'est la faute de
l'autre c'est pas ma dignité qui en
manquent cause c'est un autre qui a
voulu aborder réalité il faudrait quand
même que les élèves doivent y aller la
première chose c'est que nous parlons
dans notre texte
nous ne parlons pas de violence d'accord
je dis que frau torse et viol non je
vais écouter je vous ai écoutés donc
laissez moi elle est réalisée on peut
pas s'expliquer en un mot couper toutes
les deux secondes je vous ai écoutés
j'essaye de vous répondre
nous ne parlons de ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est à dire je veux dire
que des hommes
si vous voulez hopper vedette dénoncer
parce que ils ont eu un mot déplacé ou
pas parce qu'ils ont fait une avance
parce que l'histoire du monde est ainsi
si vous voulez améliorer les relations
il y a je veux dire effectivement il ya
une je voudrais encore une fois dire si
on me ramène tout le temps à la violence
je ne peux pas m'expliquer donc sur la
question de la violence qui est très
simple parce que la violence c'est
facile à définir
nous sommes intraitables c'est la
question moi ce qui m'a beaucoup plus
interpellé excusez moi il faut parler de
balance au port on me dit c'est
minoritaires mal an son port c'est quand
même tous les jours non tu applaudis et
là près de la direccte la salle qui a
initié balances ton port la lancer en
dénonçant nommément quelqu'un qui lui
avait dit dans une soirée tu as des gros
nibards je vais te faire jouir ça n'a
pas été plus loin
elle nous dit qu'elle a est tombé dans
une faille spatio-temporelle c'est là où
je dis puis après un siècle de féminisme
nous dire qu'une femme soit on est égaux
et quand eux
personne ne considère que si une femme
drague un homme en lui disant dis donc
toi tu as l'air d'être un bon bout le
dire personne ne va vous dire que
l'homme est humiliée et bien saoulé
quand sandra muller dit mon bourreau
bourreau bourreaux ont dit ça des nazis
un jeu dire on dit bourreau en
l'occurrence c'est le bourreau qui n'a
plus de boulot
j'essaye de dire que ya une confusion et
je voudrais dire que à mon avis les
comportements déviants existe mais
qu'ils ne sont pas la norme dans notre
pays en hausse et s'adjuge pardonnez moi
qu'on écoute marlène schiappa qu'ea
réagissez midi sur france culture elle a
été plutôt choquée par une autre tribune
en écoute dans cette tribune ya aussi
des choses qui sont profondément
choquant de voir fausses par exemple
dire éventuellement dans certains cas
peut être qu'une agression sexuelle peut
être considéré comme un délit
ce qui est dit dans cette tribune ça
n'est pas vrai je suis désolé il faut
dire le droit et moins tant que membre
du gouvernement je suis là pour rappeler
ce qu'est le droit
nous avons déjà énormément de mal à
faire comprendre aux jeunes filles que
se frotter contre elle frotte et un sexe
d'homme contre une femme dans le métro
sans son opinion c'est une agression
sexuelle ça vaut jusqu'à trois ans de
prison et 75000 euros d'amendé
on a du mal à dire aux jeunes filles
qu'elles n'ont pas éprouvé de la honte
et qu'elles ne sont pas coupables de
cela dont je pense que c'est dangereux
que de tenir ce discours
mesdames il reste deux minutes ce que je
voulais dire c'est que ce qui est
important maintenant que les femmes
comprennent ce que sont en train de
s'adresser quand même beaucoup de femmes
qui nous écoutent c'est qu'elles ont le
droit de choisir avec ici et quand c'est
sa plus importante que la violence
commence quand l'expression de leurs de
leur non consentement quand elle dit non
a été niée et que la personne commence à
assister à avoir un comportement
intimidant et a forcé voilà à force et
c'est ça le plus important est ce qui
importe parce que nous on a fait une
étude assez proche des hashtags est vrai
qu'il ya eu quelques hashtag qui ont
balancé des mangues la plupart des
hashtag n'ont même pas de nom cd non ils
ont explicité des situations et les
situations ce qui nous a choqués c'est
qu'elle était souvent gravissime et qui
jamais n'ont elle fait le pas de porter
plainte et que même elles se sont rendu
compte au moment de me tous que ce qui
leur est arrivé c'était grave c'était
délictuelle qui étaient condamnées par
la loi
moi ça faisait des années que je vivais
en france puisque la baisse je suis
marocaine
et il m'arrivait plusieurs fois d'avoir
des situations extrêmement violente au
boulot parce que j'avais des travail
précaire avec des du harcèlement sexuel
et je me disais bon ok voilà c'est ma
semafo n'est pas une fatalité que ça une
fatalité c'est la vie versées et comme
c'était des métiers prat car comme je
refuse les avances c'est moi qui n'ai
pas pu c - élise la banalise les
dernières mines et qui ai vécu des
représailles qui ai dû quitter c'est du
travail la première chose c'est que ce
que la première chose c'est que le
secours culpabiliser l'accord la
première chose je ne veux culpabiliser
personne je veux avoir le droit d'avoir
un point de vue qui n'est pas le vôtre
je suis désolé seulement des mots mais
dans le monde il n'a pas idée n'en
démordrai pas oui mais le tollé suscité
par le fait qu'on exprime une divergence
m'inquiète un peu
la première chose si vous voulez c'est
que il faut dans le texte nous disons le
franchement ce qu'on appelle le
frottement vie est un délit et on dit
simplement qu'on pu ne pas se sentir
traumatisée ah si on les bat sam c'est
tout on peut se sentir traumatisé on
peut aussi ne pas se dire voilà
et vous ne pouvez pas nous plaindre
féminisme est différent alors soir c'est
vrai vous incarnez de la deuxième chose
il faudrait vous dire c'est qu'à mon
avis ce que vous ne voyez pas c'est que
globalement le monde dans lequel nous
vivons aujourd'hui est plus sûr plus
égal si vous les plus accueillants pour
les femmes que celui dans lequel
catherine deneuve avait 20 ans
c'est très important je veux dire ne
soyons pas mauvaises gagnante
nous avons largement gagné ça n'est pas
la norme partout et la norme départ est
respecté par yann 1% d'actionnaires
annoncée dans votre conclusion jose la
vieille mine et à tiers de nos deux il
ya un tiers de délai groupe de
délinquants sexuels dans nos prisons
arrêtons de propager des chiffres
excusez moi je suis désolé il ya
certainement 135 veille à 40 hommes
aussi tués par leurs compagnes ceux là
n'ont le droit à la compassion de
personnes jeudi et en plus ça ça m'a
vraiment ma conclusion il vient dans la
sexualité dans l'expression du désir
sous les dézone troubles il y à des
expressions qui peuvent être apporte une
qui peuvent être eux est énervante qui
peuvent être déplorable je ne parle
toujours pas d'agression et bien moi je
pense que vivent dans un monde
si vous voulez le désir des hommes je
veux dire peut s'exprimer de façon tout
à fait déplorable mais moi j'ai envie de
vivre dans un monde je crois encore
générale la plupart des hommes se
comporte bien voilà je suis désolé de le
dire mais je le crois la plupart des
hommes en france c'est de luz et
s'arrêter là le lierre et il ne faut pas
si vous voulez essayer de tout normes et
oui vous pouvez être importuné néanmoins
aidant les allemands n'est pas
importuner jamais est un monde dans
lequel on est plus vivant en exil
égyptien fait quand une femme dit non
c'est non c'est important mais quand
j'ai pris une espèce cd - peu vague et
voilà comme si une femme vous dit non
vous arrêtez site merci à toutes les
deux